the Columbia University Alumni medal for
distinguished service is presented to
Maria II shall defrancesco I really was
kind of a very nice typical engineer I
had a lot of clever college friends and
they you know they tended to be model of
arts major so you know George museums
and all the Opera comes other concerns
is that check columbia found me and
without me knowing my daughter Beatrice
who is a senior in high school is gonna
be attending come to college next fall
I've obviously particularly proud that
she chose to attend Columbia I was
laughing with our dampen llamada earlier
you guys are giving me the medal but I'm
giving you my daughter he said actually
that's the most precious thing that
alums I can give us the children nine
the first thing I did is very quickly
after I graduated I was involved with
the undergrad interview admission news
interview process and then I've actually
been doing that in several countries
because i started in france and then i
did that in belgium for three years and
obviously keep doing it in London when I
was in France um we were getting very
near the 250th anniversary and there was
no alumni club that's what you know what
I thought well okay there's these three
guys and you know I could do it you know
let's let's just do it and so I did as
part of a inter generational thing I
guess he could call it it was a big big
very big gala reception at the music up
saying several hundred people came from
from all over Europe so I was a big
thing I'm very very honored I actually
would like to accept it on behalf of all
the young alumni volunteers another
world because I know a lot of them won't
ever forget it and I think I'll like to
share
you